-Our first guest tonight is an
Emmy-nominated actor and write
who you know from his work
on "Saturday Night Live,"
"The Last Man on Earth,"
and "MacGruber."
He stars in the
animated series "HouseBroken,"
which airs Monday nights
on Fox,
and his series "Sweet Tooth"
is streaming on Netflix now.
Let's take a look.
[ Vehicle engine in distance ]
-[ Gasping ]
-[ Scoffing ]
-[ Grunting ]
-What did I tell you?!
What did I tell you?!
Someone could have seen you!
-I heard something!
-What did I tell you?!
-I thought it was her!
-I told you, she's gone!
[ Scoffs ]
I told -- I told you
not to be afraid.
I thought I could trust you.
-You can!
-No, we need
to trust each other!
-I don't trust you!
You don't tell me everything
You think I'm too little.
-You are too little, Gus.
And you just proved it.
-Please welcome back
to the show
our very good friend Will Forte.
Hello. How are you, Wilbur
-Hello. I'm good.
How are you?
I have a special shirt on.
-Oh!
Thank you for the shout-out.
I really appreciate it.
This is very exciting,
and I want to get to it
later in the interview.
You are currently
in Albuquerque.
You begin filming "MacGruber
the series on Monday.
-Yes, yes.
I've been here a couple weeks.
Yeah, we've been doing
prep stuff,
and we start on Monday.
Kristen gets into town today
Ryan, the whole cast
is coming in.
It's super exciting.
-And there were
some really exciting
cast announcements
beyond the original film cast.
-Yes, yes.
Just today, we were able
to announce that --
Yeah, so, Kristen and Ryan
are both back.
And then -- very excited -
General Fasoose,
one of the main characters
in the show,
is played by Laurence Fishburne,
which we are
over the moon about.
And the main bad guy,
whose name is
Brigadier Commander
Enos Queeth...
[ Laughter ]
...all of us who have
created the show
are 50-ish,
and we did make that decision --
but Enos Queeth is played
by Mickey Rourke,
which is also very exciting,
And MacGruber's dad is played by
the one and only Sam Elliott
[ Gasps ]
-It's really, truly amazing.
I didn't think it was possible
for me to be more excited,
but that news made me
genuinely more excited.
-We're gonna wreck
so many careers.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, "Sweet Tooth"
is fantastic, as well.
This is based on a comic
that I love
by Jeff Lemire, a DC Comic
And you know, it's a role mayb
we're not used to seeing you in.
Did you have a good time?
-I had the most amazing time
It was -- There are so man
things about it that I loved
New Zealand is an amazing place.
It just was
an amazingly written project
done by a bunch of people,
but the main person
I got to single out is,
obviously, Christian Convery
who plays Sweet Tooth.
He's the sweetest young ma
and he is such a great actor
I can't say enough great
about him.
I'm so happy
that the show is doing so well
because he deserves it.
He's a hard worker
and a great actor.
-You play a loving,
protective father.
And we, of course, know
in real life now,
you're a new father.
How is life with
your little girl, so far?
-It is -- It is the best.
It's the best.
She just gets cuter every day.
Her name is Zoe.
There were some --
There were some scary times,
because when she first came out,
she was looking
quite a bit like me.
And that was a fear
that the whole family had.
[ Laughter ]
And then she started shiftin
over to her mom's looks,
which I think bodes well
for her long-term prospect
for looks and stuff.
-Have you, in your life,
ever seen someone else's bab
and thought maybe
it wasn't attractive?
-Oh, I'm very hard on babies
Yes, that happens quite a bit.
I'm very -- I'm tough on them.
I -- I'm very honest, too,
behind their backs.
Like, I will -- Yeah, I'll b
very honest with my critique
In fact, I will be --
I'll lie to the parents
and tell them that I think
that their baby is
the cutest thing I've ever seen.
But you know what?
I've come --
The babies that I have --
The main babies in my head
when I think about an ugly bab
that I have encountered,
they've grown up to be
very good-looking people.
So I don't think --
It doesn't matter what you -
what you look like as a baby
You know, you still got a shot
[ Laughter ]
It's a lesson in hope.
-That's
a really inspiring message